[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour faire la
fête la route est prête le ciel est bleu
il y a des chansons dans le piano à que
il y a de l'espoir dans tous les yeux et
des sourires dans chaque faossette la
joie nous guettete c'est merveilleux
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour faire la
fête il y a des noisettes dans le chemin
creux il y a des raisins des rouges des
blancs des Bleus les papillons s'en vont
par deux et la mille pâte mais ces
chaussettes les Alouettes font des aveux
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour faire la
fête les C répèt ses cris joyeux et la
radio chante un petit radieu les
parapluies restent chez eux les cannes
s'en vont aux bal musettes levez la tête
les amoureux qu'est-ce qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'est-ce qu'on
attend pour
tre
heureux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]